alors mon nom et natacha litzistorf
aussi pour faire encore un lien avec la
proche de monsieur vidéo à un petit
condensé de clichés suisse se griller
rienne donc je suis très contente d'être
ici
donc ça c'est une première chose mon
papa a fait toute sa carrière dans
l'horlogerie ce deuxième chose après
j'arrêterai là les clichés mais c'est
vrai que je suis assez au monde puisque
j'ai grandi en gruyère après j'ai fait
ma scolarité à genève je suis revenu à
lausanne j'ai étudié à neuchâtel
également
et puis j'adore le malais pour y avoir
travaillé aussi un peu avec le fonds
suisse pour le paysage donc c'est aussi
une approche très remonté et également
suisse
ce qui est aussi un peu le maquis fait
le la partie de ma personnalité c'est
que oui on est à l'habitude de se mettre
en scène mais non on a aussi envie de
montrer que finalement tout ce qu'on
présente et je pense que c'est aussi un
peu le ton de cette aide
c'est issus de quelque chose qu'on fait
au niveau collectif et puis là les
projets et principalement le projet que
je vais présenter aux ce soir qui tourne
autour des jardins vous l'avez vous
l'aurez compris bain se fait avec toute
une équipe ça c'est l'équipe d'équiterre
où on est un peu plus d'une dizaine de
personnes on se répartit entre un site à
berne le coeur à lausanne et encore un
autre site
à genève on travaille depuis 43 ans
justement pas tous ceux qui sont sur la
photo bien entendu sur des enjeux de
développement durable et on travaille
beaucoup avec les collectivités
publiques mais aussi avec les acteurs
privés sur des projets qui ont à voir
avec la problématique de l'aménagement
du territoire avec l'urbanisme avec le
mobilier urbain on le verra et on essaie
de marier cette grande thématique à
différents niveaux institutionnel avec
une autre thématique qui nous préoccupe
aussi beaucoup tout ce qui est à celle
de la santé ou plaisent plus
spécifiquement celle de la promotion de
la santé
alors pour présenter les projets comme
on l'a évoqué pour en introduction sur
les potagers urbains gérer on est à la
spirale dans une spirale un peu honte
aux noirs comme ça on n'ayant quelques
approches un peu plus mais t'as pour
situer un petit peu le discours est
arrivé à des choses très très concrète
et voir ce qu'on peut en tirer aussi
après dans la discussion qui aura
certainement lieu autour de la soupe de
chalet territoire là aussi par rapport à
ce qui a été évoqué par rapport au
discours de monsieur bideau dans
l'introduction
ce qu'on peut dire de la suisse de
l'attractivité de la suisse c'est vrai
qu'on a su préserver nos paysages
mais quand même pas tous partout et pas
tous bien quand même
et on imagine bien volontiers justement
que cette image parce que j'ai bien
entendu pas osé mettre une image une
collectivité suisse est la seule image
de la présentation qui n'est pas issu de
main banque de données de photos mais là
on voit quand même et c'est pas le
modèle suisse mais on sent quand même
qu'il ya eu un mitage du territoire et
des paysages par rapport à notre manière
de construire les villes et puis c'est
ce constat là qui nous mène justement à
des défis aujourd'hui d'essayer de
construire comme on le dit la ville dans
la ville de densifier
mais avec la qualité de vie en essayant
justement de pallier les effets pervers
de mitage du territoire et des paysages
qu'on connaît tous et ça c'est vraiment
le défi d'aujourd'hui
alors on s'attelle à faire aimer la
ville avec les qualités de verre dans la
ville encore une fois avec des valeurs
ajoutées à différents niveaux on le
verra les enjeux qui sont liés les
enjeux connexes par rapport à ces défis
qu'il faut relever on a pas mal aussi
parler d'agriculture c'est vrai que ces
dernières années on a un peu oublié qui
fait qu'ils font les paysages suisses
qui font l'attractivité à différents
niveaux de notre pays
c'est vrai que ce sont les paysans alors
on a un peu tendance quand on est un
théoricien de la ville à se dire qu'en
suisse on a plus qu une théâtralisation
de l'agriculture alors moi je m'inscris
pas par rapport à mon coeur de go
rienne qui bat mais quand même en faux
par rapport à ça parce que finalement on
a aussi besoin de ce type justement de
métier on leur demande beaucoup de
choses aux agriculteurs aujourd'hui et
c'est peut-être aussi le moment de se re
questionner pour voir et comprendre les
enjeux et quel est le métier qui a
derrière l'agriculture alors dans le
propos que je vais tenir un pan dont
justement encore quelques minutes c'est
de dire que finalement avec ses potagers
urbains dont on m'a parlé tout à l'heure
il y a quand même toute cette grande
aventure qui est en train de naître en
termes d'agriculture urbaine
il ya beaucoup de gens dans les villes
on le sentait toujours aussi une demande
sociale de se rapprocher de la nature
notamment l'envi de cultiver on le verra
au pied de son immeuble avec des enjeux
bien entendu qu'ils sont et la demande
sociale elle s'est beaucoup articuler
ces dernières années là autour qui
tourne autour de l'alimentation alors à
équiterre on a essayé de lancer il ya il
ya plusieurs années ces projets de faire
des potagers dans les villes ça n'a pas
très bien pris mais il ya 5 6 ans c'est
un peu mieux prix puis on se dit que
c'est peut-être lié
alors on n'aime pas trop ça mais ça fait
quand même toujours recette la pédagogie
les catastrophes
c'est vrai que tout les affaires qui a
eu lieu au niveau de la sécurité
alimentaire dont on parle beaucoup on
peut être eu un impact parce qu'on a
envie de savoir au niveau de la
traçabilité par exemple ce qu'il ya dans
nos assiettes
autre défi qui en lien avec des éléments
de santé en tout cas dans nos pays
andy m'a dit développés on a des
problèmes en terme de d'activité
physique on parle pas de sport non pas
une activité physique et on voit que
c'est un facteur qui est important dans
la santé des populations
troisième sujet angelier notamment est
toujours surtout dans nos pays dits
développés
l'évolution de la pyramide des âges
alors c'est pas très sexy et puis on
s'en sont bien au niveau politique de
parler de la politique de la vieillesse
mais ça reste quand même néanmoins un
enjeu majeur et notamment l enjeu majeur
dont les milieux urbains alors à
équiterre à notre petit niveau on a
essayé de développer en
en mettant beaucoup de passion et
beaucoup de créativité des projets à
différentes échelles qui bien entendu
sont issus de la créativité on le verra
de certaines personnes mais qui sont
aussi beaucoup issus de l'expérience et
de l'expertisé d'autres projets qui ont
eu lieu à d'autres époques et dans
d'autres pays parce que là aussi
d'innovations comme ça a été dit au
début c'est une question des changes et
d'aller voir ailleurs ce qui se passe ça
nous permet d'affiner aussi des choses
ici le coeur de l'action dans les
milieux urbains justement il faut avoir
au coeur de hautcoeur nos préoccupations
les espaces publics parce que encore une
fois c'est là que tout se passe en
termes sociologiques ça j'ai pas
m'étendre là dessus mais vous savez bien
que c'est dans ces franges aussi on le
verra au pied des immeubles entre
l'espace privé et l'espace public dans
ses franges qui a vraiment un grand
potentiel de travail et où il faut
mettre beaucoup d'énergie maintenant
pour construire les villes de pour
qu'elles soient justement durable et
vivable ce qu'on a commencé à faire
comme tout le monde et on l'a aussi
beaucoup évoqué dans les présentations
précédentes celle que tout passe et ça
fait peut-être un peu triviale de le
dire mais par la sensibilisation et
l'information et on a mis sur pied pour
différentes villes une journée de nature
en ville ça se reprend maintenant
beaucoup dans le cadre de grandes
justement manifestation sur sur toute la
suisse c'est quand même le moment où on
peut justement proposé aux acteurs de la
ville d'être acteur aussi de leur mise
en scène entre guillemets de nature en
ville et c'est ce qui fait le bonheur
justement deux des plus petits mais
aussi des adultes et ce qui était
intéressant peut-être anecdotes là pour
ceux qui connaissent lausanne
on avait fait ça sur la place pépinet
but on avait à l'aide bien entendu du
support de la ville de lausanne
verdi mais l'ensemble de la place sur
toutes les dimensions finalement les
gens quand ils sont venus nous ont dit à
ses magnifiques pour cette manifestation
en un jour vous avez planté ses
magnifiques arbres qui sont aussi grands
que les immeubles et finalement on
n'avait rien planter du tout vous en
doutez bien mais le fait de végétaliser
toute la place avait mis en évidence et
en valeur ces pauvres a requis des fois
sont un petit peu emprisonné dans le
béton il faut bien le dire
ce qu'on aime bien faire aussi de plus
longue haleine et qu'on a fait par
exemple avec yverdon les bains de la
graine à l'assiette on comprend le
propos sur une année c'est toute une
série d'activités qui permettent aux
gens de se réapproprier aussi par
rapport à l'alimentation les gestes
qu'on peut faire et notamment avec des
cours on le verra de jardinage mais
aussi à comment on fait les conserves
parce que finalement il faut s'occuper
si on veut avoir justement des valeurs
ajoutées pas négligeable faut s'occuper
de tous les maillons de la chaîne
et là on travaille avec les acteurs
locaux
c'est ce qui est aussi important de
valoriser on l'a vu aussi dans l'
approche économique
finalement ce qu'on a envie c'est
d'avoir des activités endogène qui
permettent de rester de laisser les
valeurs ajoutées pardon sur place on a
aussi développé je vous conseille
d'aller regarder et peut-être de la
faire venir ici à lausanne carottes city
c'est une exposition qui circulent dans
le monde et qui s'alimentent c'est le
cas de dire à chaque passage d'un
nouveau panneau avec un projet du lieu
là on a travaillé avec l'université de
lausanne pour monter cette expo avec des
choses très très pragmatique et la
possibilité de faire une programmation
autour de cette expo et surtout des
projets un peu plus pérenne avec
justement débute bien sûr didactique le
coeur du propos
c'est celui ci les potagers urbains pour
développer ce projet on s'est beaucoup
inspirée des expériences françaises avec
les jardins partagés qui avait mis
l'accent sur une approche plus sociale
du du jardin avec un début de projet
dans des banlieues à caractère plutôt
précarisés et on s'est inspiré de ce
projet là avec un acte social fort
intégrateurs fort et puis on fait une
identification de terrain de ce type là
que vous connaissez tous probablement
céder pelouse un peu stérile qu'on a un
pied des immeubles
donc on les identifie ensuite on
organise une séance d'information
publique où on voit si les gens ont
envie de jardiner puisqu'on va forcer
les gens à jardiner elano grande
surprise quand on a commencé le projet
il ya cinq six ans on était un peu
dubitatif et on dit est ce que ça va
marcher pas marché
il ya des gens qui vont venir et oui les
gens viennent en masse ensuite on
travaille en participation avec eux au
co construit le projet avec eux c'est
pas comme les plantages de la ville de
lausanne ou des services de la ville
font tout le projet après ils remettent
les parcelles aux gens là les gens font
eux mêmes le travail de contre
construire l'ensemble du projet ce qui
est important aussi pour nous c'est de
former les gens au jardinage écologique
pas c'est vrai qu'on a vu qu'il y avait
eu pas mal de dégâts entre guillemets
qui avait été créée à une certaine
époque parce qu'on était bien plus
d'engrais que ce qu'on voyait dans les
plus grandes productions agricoles est
très très polluante pour certaines
d'entre elles n'est pas ici en suisse
bien sûr on a vu que il fallait vraiment
andy mais si vous me passez la parole
fait du marquage à la culotte pour bien
faire en sorte que les gens mettent pas
tout et n'importe quoi pouvoir pousser
rapidement leurs seins leurs fruits et
légumes et donc il s'engage aussi
formellement signant une charte et en
suivant les cours saison après saison
qu'on leur donne et comme on peut le
voir ce qui est intéressant est ce qu'il
ya de plus en plus le cas aussi dans ses
démarches participatives
c'est qu'au début les la population
voulait participer à la conception mais
maintenant on voit que les gens ils ont
vite donné leur temps pour créer eux
mêmes leurs espaces publics et c'est
aussi le cas pour le jardin donc
l'ensemble de la mise en place du jardin
se fait avec les gens les valeurs
ajoutées elles sont nombreuses en terme
de biodiversité ça c'est pas négligeable
on reconnaît aussi les hôtels à insectes
on travaille beaucoup nous avec des
fondations aussi qui travaille avec des
personnes qui sont en précarité ou en
difficulté en termes de santé pour faire
c'est ce genre d'aménagement ont fait
des aménagements qui sont comme vous
pouvez le voir très très sobre l'idée
c'est de se dire qu'à un moment donné si
on a envie de faire autre chose de cet
espace est toujours possible parce que
les aménagements sont très très léger
avec une mutualisation des des houthis
et pas chacun qui a s'appelle et son
arrosoir donc on partage aussi les
choses il y a bien entendu l'aspect
compost qui est intéressant et qui amène
aussi le l'écogeste qu'il faut dans le
jardin les valeurs ajoutées principe
al se situe beaucoup sur le domaine et
le pôle social de ce genre de projet on
voit très bien et puis on se je pense
que vous le sentez aussi chez vous dans
ces grands ensembles souvent ou dans les
villes on connaît pas tellement bien son
voisin et c'est une manière d'entrer en
contact avec son voisin il ya de belles
choses qui se passent en termes de
création nationale on voit que c'est
aussi un des derniers lieux où on a de
la mixité sociale
il ya des cols blancs il ya des cols
bleus il ya des personnes âgées il ya
des enfants il ya des gens en bonne
santé il ya des gens en moins bonne
santé
on a fait maintenant une quinzaine de
potagers en suisse romande
bien entendu on travaille beaucoup avec
des instituts universitaires pour nous
aider à faire des évaluations et comme
j'ai dit les principales valeurs a
ajouté qu'on voit dans les évaluations
c'est clair que c'est en termes de lien
social
mais en termes d'alimentation et celle
là qui c'est intéressant pour avoir
travaillé pendant des années dans la
promotion de la santé sur des grands
programmes avec des objectifs très
ambitieux etc
on n'a jamais atteint les objectifs
comment les a atteint après une saison
de jardinage ans quand on interroge les
gens ils nous disent ou alors après tout
ce que j'ai sué dans mon jardin
moi je mange le soir j'invite mes amis
je murray a soit à table avec ma famille
etc
puis ben je mange des fruits et des
légumes je mange de saison et puis bien
entendu je mange de proximité hélas ce
qui est intéressant à avoir c'est que en
une saison on arrive à changer un
comportement alimentaire pas de manière
radicale mais en tout cas on a déjà semé
une graine qui est intéressante à ce
propos là on pourrait aussi parler mais
comme le temps tout mais j'ai quand même
pas abuser aussi des valeurs ajoutées
mais qui sont importantes en termes
économiques
on voit que des ménages qui sont
précarisées où on voit très carisa sion
avoir un lopin d'une certaine taille
celle qui vous un 13e salaire donc ce
n'est pas négligeable pour pour ce type
de ménage d'un point de vue économique
aussi mais alors là du côté des
propriétaires
on voit très bien que une pelouse
entretenir ça coûte de l'argent
si on met un potager urbain dessus ben
c'est les gens qui entretiennent sa
sécurisé les lieux ça passe i feel et
les quartiers c'est vrai que c'est
valeur ajoutée là elles sont pas
négligeable non plus on fait la même
chose
très rapidement sur
les balcons avec ce projet pink balcony
avec les deux créatrices qu'elle a piqué
hélène gaillard qui se sont dit bah on
fait ça au pied des immeubles mais on
n'a pas tous la possibilité d'avoir une
pelouse et d'utiliser la pelouse au pied
des immeubles faisons ça sur nos balcons
c'est un projet qui marche très très
bien on essaie de faire aussi en sorte
de mettre ça un peu plus dans dé
planification urbanistique et là on
travaille par exemple avec la ville de
lausanne sur un plan partiel
d'affectation ou on amorce la pompe si
vous me passez l'expression environ des
aménagements éphémère avec ses petits
potagers qui permettent de construire le
devenir d'un morceau de ville qui va se
construire assez blanc et d'un morceau
de ville qu'on souhaiterait avec plus de
nature en ville
mon gros sous r on a beaucoup parlé de
mise en réseau aussi ce soit c'est de
créer une communauté des jardins de
toujours de toutes tailles et ça c'est
un appel que je fais aussi peut-être
monsieur cra au fond de ligne je sais
pas s'il est toujours là mais je pense
qu'il intéresse beaucoup de monde dans
la salle
si on peut développer ça c'est une belle
chose mais ce qui me tient très à coeur
dans le fond avec ces projets là c'est
qu'on rejette les ponts entre la ville
et la campagne même si en termes
urbanistique qu'il ya peut-être
urbanistes dans la ville savait plus
rien dire pour certains villes et
campagnes mais on sent qu'on a besoin de
renouer les liens entre la ville et la
campagne
moi je plaide vraiment pour un nouveau
pacte parce qu'il ya vraiment quelque
chose à faire c'est projet de potager
urbain on sent très bien et c'est comme
ça que j'ai essayé de convaincre
monsieur jacques bourgeois de l'union
suisse des paysans on sent bien que les
gens quand ils vont au magasin il ne
garde pas les produits de la même
manière une fois qu'ils ont cultivé eux
mêmes et dans les évaluations qu'on a
fait
ils disent très souvent qu'ils se
dirigent maintenant plus facilement vers
des produits suisses de proximité et de
saison
on essaye de justement marié aussi les
différents types d'agriculture là on a
représentant d'uniterre on essaie de
marier ces types d'agriculture mais
encore une fois avec ce pacte ville
campagne nous pensons que nous avons une
possibilité de participer soyons un
petit peu pas modeste mais un peu plus
de cohésion nationale et c'est des
choses qui font du bien en ces temps là
alors
vous remercie beaucoup peut-être je me
permette encore vite vite mais je parle
plus il ya un dernier c'est le petit
film qui montre que justement ces
projets de potagers urbains comme les
dizaines certains clips c'est facile
c'est passionnant